Speaker 1: There's a fascinating new chart
from The New York Times and the MIT Media Lab,
and this compares covid cases per 100 people,
meaning per capita covid to how people voted
in the 20 20 presidential election. And the
results are so simple that it's almost surprising.
But then once you think about it, once you look
at it, you realize actually it's not really that
surprising. And the bottom line of the findings
are as follows. If there are lots of Trump voters,
there's lots of covid right now over the last
month, if there's a medium amount of Trump voters,
there's a medium amount of covid over the last
month. And if there aren't that many Trump voters,
there's really not that much covid spreading
either. So let's take a look at the image
and very, very nicely put together. So what you're
seeing here are five separate lines which track
new cases per 100000. So the blue line means there
are under 20 percent Trump voters in the county.
This is a county by county thing. If you're not
watching, I'm going to describe this to you. And
then it goes from the blue line all the way up
to the bright red line. That means more than
80 percent of a county has Trump voters. Now,
remember that if you go back to the beginning
before we knew much about covid early covid hit
the places with the big airports that are directly
connected to Asia and Europe. And those are mostly
in blue states. So early on at the start of the
pandemic and you look to the left side of the
chart in April, you saw that it was blue counties
with more covid because we had this airport
based initial spread. You had New York City,
you had Boston, Newark Airport over over the water
in Jersey, San Francisco, eventually L.A., etc..
Now, after a year and a half of the pandemic,
having vaccines, understanding guidelines,
you've essentially seen that since roughly August
or September of twenty twenty. It's been the red
counties that on a per capita basis are leading
the covid case rates. The more red the county,
the more they are leading in terms of cases.
And that's not good. The lowest new case rates
right now are in the counties with fewer than 20
percent of the population, less than 20 percent
of the population, fewer than 20 percent Trump
voters. Those are the places with the least covid,
followed by the places with 20 to 40 percent Trump
and then the places with 40 to 60 percent Trump.
Voters have more covid and then the places with
60 to 80 percent Trump have more covid. And the
places over the last month with the highest
per capita covid case rates are the counties
where more than 80 percent of the population voted
for Donald Trump. And it's not by a small margin
if you look at those 20 or lower percent Trump
counties. They only have 25 new cases per 100000.
If you look at the 80 plus percent Trump counties,
they have sixty five new cases per 100000.
In other words, the big Trump counties have
about two and a half, just shy of three times
the new case rate, then do the very Democratic
leaning counties. It's truly incredible to see
this translate perfectly into virus spread now.
We expected this intuitively. We expected this,
but the data shows it cleanly and clearly. Now,
you might correctly say this can't be good for
winning elections, right? Like in other words,
if it's mostly your voters who are getting sick
and overwhelmingly your voters that are going to
the hospital and overwhelmingly your voters that
are dying, that probably isn't good for winning
elections. Right. And you would be completely
correct, except Republicans aren't actually trying
to win by having more people who agree with them
go out and vote Republicans for a long time and
recently and into the future are trying to win by
planning to suppress the vote and making it harder
for people unlikely to vote for them to actually
be able to get a vote counted, not by winning
people over on policy ideas. That being said,
let's go back to the discussion that we had
last week. Last week, we talked about how
Florida's death toll now exceeds Ron DeSantis
margin of victory in twenty eighteen. Now,
it's not relevant yet because that death toll
includes includes children who don't vote,
who weren't part of that margin of victory. It
includes nonvoter, non-voting adults as well.
And it's a mix of Republicans and Democrats.
But it is absolutely plausible that over time,
the partizan split in deaths, if it continues
to shift to where it goes to be, 55 percent of
the deaths are Republicans, 60 percent of the
deaths are Republicans, 70 percent. Eventually,
you could get a partizan gap such that you have
enough additional Republicans dying of covid
that it starts to impact elections. Now, sadly,
we can't just look away and say to each their own,
let them go and kill themselves because vaccinated
people still can get sick. Not everybody can get
vaccinated. Vaccinated people could end up in the
hospital vaccinated. People could end up dying,
in part thanks to the increased spread caused
by the right wing anti vaccine people. But it's
a very similar pattern to what we saw with the
Spanish flu earlier. Urban areas got hit harder.
We saw that with covid as well, more because
of airports. It's unclear about the effect of
the population density, but there may be one. But
by the end of the day, by now, what we are seeing
is that it's the most conservative areas, the
most Trump voting areas, many of which are rural
that are getting hit the hardest. And it's
two things. It's the lower rate of vaccination
and it's the higher rate of ignoring all of
the guidelines that at this point we have
a pretty good understanding of in terms of
preventing covid. So an unsurprising chart,
but very informative in terms of it can feel
vague. I don't know. We can't see the virus.
I'm just with friends. This can't be a bad
thing or I didn't get a shot. But again,
it translates to real world data and we see
it very clearly. They're not a factor. Here
are religious beliefs. But the Republican
governor of Mississippi, Tate Reeves,
certainly seems to think that that is a factor.
And I want to talk about that a little bit next.